Tasha: 好脏啊眼睛布呢
Tasha: So dirty, where's the eyeglass cloth?
小owv ：我的眼睛在
Speaker 2: My eyes are...
Shure: (歌声)嘟嘟嘟嘟嘟
Shure: (singing) Doo doo doo doo doo
音乐声：na
Music: na
音乐声：na na
Music: na na
音乐声：na
Music: na
音乐声：月光光照入了屋檐
Music: Moonlight shines through the eaves
Shure: 我已经告别了农民一个字
Shure: I've already said goodbye to being a farmer
音乐声：哒哒滴哒哒哒给你知道
Music: Da da dee da da da, let you know
Tasha: 对啊
Tasha: Yeah
Tasha: 因为你说这样就不用发我的工资了
Tasha: Because you said this way you don't have to pay me
Jake:哦确实
Jake: Oh, indeed
Tasha: 你不就这个意思吗
Tasha: Isn't that what you meant?
音乐声 ：在你的
Music: In your...
音乐声：曾经那个我们
Music: The us from before...
音乐声
Music
音乐声：beneath kosakiaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaa
Music: Beneath kosakiaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaa
音乐声：你
Music: You
音乐声：let's go
Music: Let's go
Jake:咱今整点啥
Jake: What are we going to do today?
Tasha: 要啥都可以
Tasha: Anything you want
小薇 ：要做多少要做多少
Tasha: How much do we need to make?
Jake:做多少都可以
Jake: Any amount is fine
Tasha: 现在开始做也可以
Tasha: We can start making it now
Tasha: 得做  做
Tasha: We need to make, make
Tasha: 你想吃什么
Tasha: What do you want to eat?
Jake:嗯还有啥没做的吗
Jake: Hmm, is there anything we haven't made yet?
Tasha: 芋头芋头
Tasha: Taro, taro
Tasha: 吃不了芋头芋头到不了了
Tasha: Can't eat taro, we can't get taro
Jake:芋头啊好嘞
Jake: Taro, okay
Shure: 请塔莎老师
Shure: Please, Tasha
Jake:为啥呀
Jake: Why?
Shure: 咖啡
Shure: Coffee
Tasha: 怎么了哦
Tasha: What's up, oh
Jake:傻傻的咖啡
Jake: Silly coffee
Tasha: 你是热的
Tasha: Are you hot?
Jake:放点冰块
Jake: Put some ice cubes
Jake:呵咱冰块是说要买是吧
Jake: Haha, we need to buy ice cubes, right?
Shure: 冰块有
Shure: Ice cubes are here.
Jake:冰块有有了
Jake: Ice cubes are here, got them.
Jake:是吗哪了好买了是吧
Jake: Really? Where did you buy them from?
Shure: 是的
Shure: Yes.
Tasha: 哪呢
Tasha: Where are they?
Shure: 在楼下的那个
Shure: Downstairs.
Tasha: 哦冰格里是吗
Tasha: Oh, in the ice tray?
Shure: 不是就是上次想起来没对
Shure: No, I just remembered last time, no.
Katrina: 你美团送
Katrina: Did you get it delivered?
Katrina: 送的那一坨
Katrina: The one from Meituan?
Shure: 凑单然后我凑了一袋瓶
Shure: I added it to the order to meet the minimum.
Tasha: 你要吗
Tasha: Do you need it?
Shure: 我不用
Shure: I don't need it.
Shure: 你先用吧
Shure: You use it first.
Jake:好加冰
Jake: Okay, add the ice.
Jake:你不要
Jake: You don't want it?
Tasha: 不能喝冰
Tasha: I can't drink anything cold.
Jake:你你你又不是直接视频
Jake: It's not like you're on camera.
Lucia: 所以只不过我就是因为我家在西安
Lucia: So it's just because my family is in Xi'an.
Lucia: 我就是我毕业的
Lucia: I just graduated.
Lucia: 所以我现对
Lucia: So now I...
Lucia: 所以我现在就是平常不在北京
Lucia: So now I usually don't stay in Beijing.
Lucia: 所以假如说不是即刻连着
Lucia: So if it's not an immediate thing...
Lucia: 就要搞那个什么的话
Lucia: If I have to do something...
Lucia: 我就需要先回下家
Lucia: I need to go home first.
Lucia: 不然还在北京租房子麻烦的很
Lucia: Otherwise, renting in Beijing is really troublesome.
Alice:去三亚有什么规划吗
Alice: Do you have any plans for Sanya?
Tasha: 啊
Tasha: Huh?
Lucia: 破房
Lucia: Broken house.
Tasha: 我又让你破网了
Tasha: Did I mess up your network again?
Tasha: 是的，我让杨老板也破防了
Tasha: Yeah, I messed up Jake's too.
Lucia: 我想问一下他破什么房了
Lucia: I want to ask what he broke.
Lucia: 杨 老板轻轻的破防
Shure: 有没有可能
Shure: Is it possible...
Shure: 有没有可能 10天主要是
Shure: Is it possible that within 10 days...
Lucia: 这么便宜
Lucia: So cheap.
Lucia: 一个月才只要一千多
Lucia: It's only a bit over a thousand a month.
Tasha: 但是老板离那个新加坡近
Tasha: But the boss is closer to Singapore.
Lucia: 只要30块钱哦哈哈哈
Lucia: It's only 30 yuan, hahaha.
Alice:3小时
Alice: 3 hours.
Lucia: 哦他这转的机啊缩嘎
Lucia: Oh, he's doing a spin move, huh?
Alice:那这个房间呢
Alice: What about this room?
Tasha: 2,000 一天1,000 嗯
Tasha: 2,000 a day, 1,000 per day, hmm.
Alice:一天
Alice: Per day?
Shure: 对可以直接点盒马外送的其实
Shure: Yeah, you can just order from Hema Delivery, actually.
Alice:啊 1,300一天
Alice: Ah, 1,300 per day?
Alice:1,500一天
Alice: 1,500 per day?
Tasha: 他说弄了2万
Tasha: He said he made 20,000.
Shure: 对算押金
Shure: Yeah, it's considered a deposit.
Tasha: 哦算押金
Tasha: Oh, it's considered a deposit.
Alice:丢盔弃甲破大房了
Alice: Threw in the towel and lost the big house.
Lucia: 可能因为是北京的缘故吧
Lucia: Maybe it's because it's Beijing.
Tasha: 你决定转战三亚了他们
Tasha: You decided to move to Sanya, right?
Lucia: 可以可以
Lucia: Sure, sure.
Lucia: 刚好我没去过三亚
Lucia: I haven't been to Sanya yet.
Lucia: 如果你们到时候那个啥的话可以
Lucia: If you guys go, I can...
Lucia: 我可以我可以再去玩
Lucia: I can go and have fun too.
Lucia: 我今年8月份之前应该都有空哈哈
Lucia: I should be free until August this year, haha.
Shure: 卧槽啊他一直发网络问题
Shure: Damn, he's been having network issues all along.
Jake:仨给抢了呀
Jake: They snatched three.
Jake:哎不行啊
Jake: Oh no, it's not working.
Jake:为了10年之后的10个亿
Jake: For the 1 billion in 10 years.
Alice:你怎么了微微
Alice: What's wrong, Tasha?
Tasha: 好酸
Tasha: So sour.
Jake:对必须搞
Jake: Yeah, we have to do it.
Alice:你说你弄的啥呀
Alice: What are you working on?
Jake:今天必须搞
Jake: We must do it today.
Lucia: 10个小目标
Lucia: 10 small goals.
Tasha: 他楼上冲的黑咖啡
Tasha: He's making black coffee upstairs.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Tasha: 哎
Tasha: Hey.
Alice:哈
Alice: Ha.
Alice:咖啡可以苦不能酸
Alice: Coffee can be bitter, not sour.
Tasha: 是的  加点奶吧
Tasha: Yeah, add some milk.
Tasha: 啊，怎么了
Tasha: Ah, what's wrong?
Lucia: 啊没事
Lucia: Ah, nothing.
Lucia: 可能是打针的问题
Lucia: Maybe it's because of the injection.
Jake:该怎么看待这个事
Jake: How should we view this?
Tasha: 好，就这样吧
Tasha: Alright, let's leave it at that.
Tasha: 杨 老板
Tasha: Jake.
Jake:哎
Jake: Hey
Tasha: 我们今天要再采购一次
Tasha: We need to go shopping again today.
Tasha: 然后再做甜品
Tasha: And then make some desserts.
Tasha: 牛奶也没了
Tasha: We're out of milk too.
Jake:那就买呗
Jake: Then let's buy some.
Tasha: 那是去超市还是直接手机上买
Tasha: Should we go to the supermarket or just order online?
其他人：这个簪子好好看
Others: This hairpin is so pretty.
Tasha: 哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha
Jake:一会问一下大家有没有别的要买
Jake: Ask everyone if they need anything else.
Jake:或者比方说你没到的东西
Jake: Or for example, if there's something you didn't get.
Jake:如果多的话直接出去买
Jake: If there's a lot, we can just go out and buy it.
Tasha: 好呀
Tasha: Sure.
Jake:去超市买
Jake: Let's go to the supermarket.
Jake:威亚还有什么没到的东西吗
Jake: Tasha, is there anything else you didn't get?
Lucia: 我的欧根纱和一个就是镭射反光纸
Lucia: My organza and a piece of laser reflective paper.
Jake:东西能买到吗
Jake: Can we buy those?
Lucia: 不知道哈哈
Lucia: I don't know, haha.
Jake:不知道哈哈哈
Jake: I don't know, haha.
Lucia: 我们可以在外面多逛逛
Lucia: We can look around outside more.
Lucia: 让我看看
Lucia: Let me check.
Lucia: 如果如果时间允许
Lucia: If time allows.
Jake:这可以商量商量时间
Jake: We can discuss the timing.
Jake:看看时间不多了
Jake: It looks like there's not much time left.
Lucia: 这明天明天活动的话
Lucia: If there's an event tomorrow,
Lucia: 我们是不是得把这俩客厅收拾收拾
Lucia: Should we tidy up the living room?
Tasha: 我见不得人
Tasha: I can't stand it.
Lucia: 哈哈哈我们这个客厅现在状态
Lucia: Hahaha, the state of our living room now.
Lucia: 会不会过于真实了
Lucia: Is it too real?
Jake:们压花怎么说
Jake: How about our pressed flowers?
Jake:我们压花现在是什么
Jake: What's the status of our pressed flowers?
Lucia: 昨天的压花可以取了吗
Lucia: Can we take the pressed flowers from yesterday?
Lucia: 哎没有我刚打开的
Lucia: Oh, no, I just opened it.
Lucia: 可以好的
Lucia: It's okay, it's good.
Lucia: 我刚才就是把它打开
Lucia: I just opened it.
Lucia: 之后在想能不能就是整个拆开
Lucia: Then I was wondering if I could take it all apart.
Lucia: 但我又不敢
Lucia: But I didn't dare.
Lucia: 所以我又没拆
Lucia: So I didn't.
Jake:然后这些花是放回卧室是吗还是搁这
Jake: Then should we put these flowers back in the bedroom or leave them here?
Katrina: 可以放回卧室
Katrina: We can put them back in the bedroom.
Lucia: 可以放回卧室吧
Lucia: We can put them back in the bedroom, right?
Jake:那就放回卧室吧
Jake: Then let's put it back in the bedroom.
Katrina: 今天等一会下午看一下有没有压
Katrina: Let's wait until this afternoon to see if there's any pressure.
Katrina: 好的有的
Katrina: Alright, there is.
Katrina: 那个花瓣可能就好了
Katrina: Those petals might be ready.
Katrina: 就可以自己做
Katrina: You can make it yourself.
Katrina: 就明信片
Katrina: The postcard.
Jake:那我们先把这个花给放回去
Jake: Let's put these flowers back first.
Jake:让客厅看起来东西少一点
Jake: To make the living room look less cluttered.
Tasha: 放到哪
Tasha: Where should we put them?
Alice:自己的屋里
Alice: In your own room.
Jake:自个卧室
Jake: In your bedroom.
Tasha: 怎么安装它呢
Tasha: How do we install it?
Tasha: 明天就是最后一天了
Tasha: Tomorrow is the last day.
Alice:明天到了第二天
Alice: Tomorrow will be the second day.
Alice:周一不是还有干嘛什么的
Alice: Isn't there something on Monday?
Tasha: 没，周一 好像就是收尾
Tasha: No, Monday is just the wrap-up.
Alice:嗯
Alice: Hmm.
Alice:周一晚上走还是周二
Alice: Are we leaving Monday night or Tuesday?
Tasha: 嗯不知道呢
Tasha: Hmm, I don't know.
Tasha: 我也没想好
Tasha: I haven't decided yet.
Tasha: 呢
Tasha: Hmm.
Tasha: 没事儿，我可能要问问 客服了
Tasha: No worries, I might need to ask customer service.
Alice:平时喜欢去探店吗
Alice: Do you like exploring new stores?
Tasha: 我吗
Tasha: Me?
Alice:嗯
Alice: Yeah.
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Yeah.
Tasha: 我觉得探店的那种店应该会比较贵吧
Tasha: I think those stores might be more expensive.
Tasha: 就是价格
Tasha: Like the price.
Alice: ：呃不一定
Alice: Well, not necessarily.
Alice:不过北京也没有特别便宜的
Alice: But there aren't many cheap ones in Beijing.
Alice:一般来说就是就算同一个品质的
Alice: Generally speaking, even with the same quality,
Alice:北京也会比周边地区贵一点
Alice: Beijing is a bit more expensive than surrounding areas.
Tasha: 嗯感觉看的店都是网红店
Tasha: Hmm, feels like the stores I see are all internet-famous ones.
Tasha: 网红店就是偏贵一些
Alice:我也不知道北京有那种什么小众的
Alice: I don't know if Beijing has any niche,
Alice:那种好吃的店
Alice: but tasty places.
Alice:一般小众的话容易开不下去吧
Alice: Generally, niche ones are hard to keep open.
Tasha: 啊
Tasha: Ah.
Tasha: 这个样子啊  好吧
Tasha: Like this, alright.
Tasha: 懂啦 懂啦
Tasha: Got it, got it.
Tasha: 懂啦啦
Tasha: Understood.
Tasha: 懂啦 懂啦
Tasha: I get it, I get it.
Tasha: 没呢
Tasha: Not yet.
Alice:你五一确定好了吗
Alice: Have you confirmed your plans for May 1st?
Alice:票还没有确定
Alice: The tickets aren't confirmed yet.
Tasha: 也没抢到
Tasha: I didn't get them either.
Tasha: 行吧
Tasha: Okay.
Tasha: 要不要去吃饭
Tasha: Want to go eat?
Tasha: 饭到了
Tasha: The food is here.
Alice:我们是不是不能在墙上贴东西
Alice: Are we not allowed to stick things on the wall?
Alice:但是不贴东西墙面巨空
Alice: But if we don't, the wall looks so empty.
Alice:我就在想
Alice: I'm just thinking...
Alice:嗯
Alice: Hmm.
Alice:偷偷的摁几个胶应该也不会被发现吧
Alice: Maybe if we secretly use some tape, no one will notice?
Tasha: 哈哈
Tasha: Haha.
Tasha: 是在二楼吃吗
Tasha: Are we eating on the second floor?
Tasha: 哎吃饭了吗
Tasha: Hey, have you eaten yet?
Lucia: 这芒果有85.8克
Lucia: This mango weighs 85.8 grams.
Tasha: 你要开始转化率了吗
Tasha: Are you going to calculate the conversion rate?
Lucia: 对
Lucia: Yes.
Alice:干嘛呀
Alice: What for?
Lucia: 不是是杨老板要开始转化他了
Lucia: No, it's Jake who wants to calculate it.
Tasha: 吃
Tasha: Eat.
Tasha: 饭了吗
Tasha: Have you eaten?
Jake:吃卤煮
Jake: Eat some stewed meat.
Tasha: 啊
Tasha: Huh?
Jake:上楼吃卤煮
Jake: Go upstairs and eat stewed meat.
Tasha: 你骗我吗
Tasha: Are you lying to me?
Jake:啊还有火烧
Jake: Ah, there's also baked wheat cakes.
Jake:火烧有奶了
Jake: The wheat cakes have milk.
Jake:我还得出去一趟
Jake: I still need to go out once.
Tasha: 行我不吃
Tasha: Fine, I won't eat.
Alice:要转化他干嘛
Alice: Why do you need to convert it?
Lucia: 没有没有
Lucia: No, no.
Lucia: 我们那天那个啥做甜点的说闹着玩了
Lucia: The other day, the dessert maker was just kidding.
Lucia: 就是说看那一个芒果能削出多少来
Lucia: They wanted to see how much mango they could peel.
Tasha: 肉
Tasha: The flesh?
Lucia: 对不是是因为金康他头一回削的时候
Lucia: Yes, because Jin Kang was peeling it for the first time.
Tasha: 边吃边削
Tasha: Peeling while eating.
Lucia: 所以他削开
Lucia: 不是本来就很小吗
Lucia: 然后好多肉都粘在那个皮上
Lucia: 对然后然后听他说这怎么回事
Lucia: 我说正确打开方式是把那个皮剥开
Lucia: 然后把它吃掉
Lucia: 我需要一个
Lucia: 充电宝
Lucia: 让我看看他这有没有
Lucia: 我需要一个充电宝
Jake:没有了是吧
Tasha: what's this 煎饼果子
Lucia: 那个太大了
Lucia: 我这裙子没有口袋
Jake:太大了这个
Shure: two
Jake:这个可能还行
Tasha: 这是什么？
Lucia: 这是充电宝啊
Jake:这是充电宝啊
Jake:对你可以试试你插上之后过一会看看
Jake: Yeah, you can try plugging it in and checking it after a bit.
Jake:他正在充电对
Jake: It's charging now.
Tasha: 吃饭了
Tasha: Time to eat!
Shure: 可以上去吃
Shure: We can go up and eat.
Shure: 准备吃上去
Shure: Let's get ready to go up and eat.
Shure: 然后呢
Shure: So, then what?
Jake:我要转化帮我提谢谢
Jake: I need to transfer, can you help me? Thanks.
Jake:我转化一下
Jake: I'll transfer it now.
Shure: 往右扭头是咖啡味
Shure: Turn your head to the right, and it smells like coffee.
Shure: 往左扭头是大肠哈哈哈
Shure: Turn your head to the left, and it smells like intestines, haha.
Alice:哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.